- During the movie, you
celebrated your birthday
with, is it the mordida? Mordida?
- Yeah.
- Is that how you say it?
- Okay, okay. I was trying to sound cool.
So could you explain what that is?
- Yeah.
There is a tradition
that we have in Mexico
that when the cake comes,
you make a wish, you blow the candle,
and then you take a bite of the cake,
and then somebody behind
you whacks you on the head
and puts your face inside of the cake.
Very normal in Mexico.
And so, let me tell you, I
didn't have a birthday party.
I just had a bunch of
people that just showed up.
- And were they all signing up--
- But it was not like a
surprise party. No, no, no.
They're like, you know,
it's your birthday,
we came to say hello. Where's the food?
But there was no party. But
it ended up being a party.
And Angie, who's so lovely,
I had dinner with her the day before,
and she just came to bring me a gift,
but she kind of stayed.
So all of a sudden--
- She kind of stayed. Oh my God. (laughs)
- All of a sudden, we were
like 15 people, 20 people.
I was working there with my
team, so they just stayed also,
And we just had a like impromptu party.
That's why you don't
see me all dressed up.
And my agent sent me a
cake, so we did the mordida,
but Angie was sitting next to me, okay?
And when everybody started, "Mordida!"
She's like, what's happening?
And I said, oh, this is tradition,
and you're sitting next to
me, so you get to put...
She goes, I'm not gonna do
that! Are you guys kidding me?
I said, No, no, no, no.
Really, it's a tradition.
Somebody whacks you in
the head inside of a cake.
- That's a weird tradition!
- And I said, yeah,
just do it, it's okay.
I can't, just do it.
And all of a sudden she's like very girly.
And all of a sudden she goes like, pwom!
(Kelly laughing)
She was worse than Valentina!
And I'm afraid of my daughter
when it comes to the mordida.
But you know what? She'll
have a birthday coming.